hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is a macbook air now if i didn't tell
you what year or model it was you
wouldn't really exactly know because on
the outside this is pretty much exactly
the same as the previous year's model
but they dropped a lot of changes on the
inside that make it a lot better now
apple's not the only one to do this a
lot of other manufacturers have dropped
haswell chips in the latest generation
of existing laptops and made them about
a thousand times better by doing so but
this is it this is apple's new machine
so without any further ado it's time to
give the full review treatment to the
2013 macbook air and the first thing
you'll notice is that literally
everything on the outside of this laptop
is exactly the same as the outside of
the 2012 macbook air it's the same
design same display same thinness same
ports same hinge same backlit keyboard
even everything's the same the one thing
that changed to be able to identify the
new air over the old one is that
microphone so now there's a dual
microphone port on the left hand side
all the other ports however on this
macbook air are the same the design has
basically remained unchanged now that's
not necessarily a bad thing considering
the 2012 macbook air design isn't
exactly bad a lot of people love it but
a lot of people were hoping like me that
the retina display would come to this
new machine a really high resolution
display unfortunately apple just refuses
to make a retina macbook air anytime
soon they're basically too busy
protecting their retina macbook pro
lineup which sucks but that's just apple
so here we are with a 1440x900 panel
which isn't bad at all but if you're
coming from using a device with a really
high pixel density you're absolutely
going to notice pixels but outside of
that this is still a pretty great laptop
display pretty standard with decent
brightness and colors and viewing angles
and the whole nine i just wish it was at
least 1080p whatever so the outside of
this machine is the same as the old one
so what's changed well the story here is
haswell this machine you're looking at
here comes with carrying intel's fourth
generation core i7 haswell cpu clocked
at 1.7 gigahertz with the intel hd 5000
graphics inside and this is really the
only reason to buy this machine over any
other one now haswell cpus have a
seriously impressive power and heat
management system that essentially
double battery life now the macbook air
was already mostly battery on the inside
it's got a battery slightly larger than
a lot of other ultrabooks measuring in
at
7150 milliamp hours it's pretty much the
entire bottom of the machine these days
but with the new haswell cpus they're
estimated to last 12 hours of use on a
single charge straight through that is
actual all-day battery life computing
with this 13-inch model with heavy
gaming or graphics work or even some
video editing which this machine can
actually handle you'll see that life
shift down to about five or six hours on
his charge straight through but lighter
not so intensive stuff this machine will
just keep going it's estimated uh
sometimes past 14 hours of battery
remaining for me so that's freaking
awesome for a laptop now there's also
the 11 inch haswell macbook air that my
buddy austin over at duncan 33303 is
reviewing so i'll link his review down
below that like button if you want to
check it out but that 11 inch air is
supposed to get 9 hours on a charge as
well so you can thank haswell for
literally changing the way we use
laptops because of that massive heat
improvement so thanks intel now you
would think with all these power
conservations this performance would
drop through the floor well not so again
until to the rescue these clock speeds
are already pretty solid like we said
this is the 1.7 gigahertz model and it
benchmarks pretty well somewhere between
the latest mac mini and the latest imac
which is nice so everyday performance is
still snappy quick and efficient which
you would expect out of a laptop of this
price and there are also some other
internal improvements that make that
possible first of all an 802.11 ac wi-fi
receiver is now in there for faster
available wireless speeds and a
pci-based ssd delivering significantly
faster read and write speeds from the
disk when compared to sata based ssds of
the older models so you're going to get
silly fast opening and closing of apps
and reading and writing of data all
that's going to happen at blazing fast
speeds thanks to that pci-based ssd so
all in all it just made too much sense
for apple apple is known for incremental
improvements and this is just the
perfect incremental improvement for the
macbook air for them keep the same
design the same body same materials same
manufacturing process but drop some
intel innovation in there with some you
know pci-based ssds and some other minor
improvements and reap the profits
because everyone loves 12 hours of
battery that is the main headliner for
this machine and i love it too so it's
almost as if apple has delivered an
extended version of the 2012 macbook air
where you get almost the same user
experience but it just lasts for much
much longer on this new machine you're
going to get a very friendly machine as
well with again that big glass track pad
the all metal construction the solid
build quality all the things you would
expect out of a premium notebook over a
thousand dollars you pretty much get it
with the macbook air you can put windows
on it if you want you won't get the same
performance and you won't get quite the
same battery life but it'll still last
pretty long time like a boss overall
it's a very friendly machine i am a fan
of the pci-based ssds it's something
i've always really wanted in a mobile
machine and now we got it so yeah at the
end of the day this is basically in
classic apple style the same machine as
the previous generation with some minor
tweaks inside but that one minor tweak
being the chip ends up making a huge
difference now in terms of who would buy
this machine and who shouldn't i
personally
can't quite stay with this machine
because of one thing and that's the
display the display is 1440 by 900 on a
13 inch display which is fine that's
ordinarily great for most people but
coming from using a
2560x1600 display in the retina macbook
air i can't do it i can't switch to
being able to see pixels where i usually
couldn't so i'm going to keep sticking
with the retina display macbooks and i'm
probably going to be upgrading to the
haswell retina macbook pro the 13 inch
when that comes out because that seems
like a logical upgrade for me because my
eyes are so used to a retina display but
either way let me know what would you
pick would you pick a retina macbook pro
or would you rather have seen a retina
macbook air or maybe would you get this
regular macbook air let me know down in
the comment section right below that
like button either way thank you for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next video peace
you